okay four people joining our live stream
this is looking at computational
chemistry for the upcoming version of
Wolfram language and we've I don't even
know what serial number of meeting this
is but it's lots but we're close to the
end I hope okay so what do I do here do
I need the patent install yes that whole
initial cell um okay so
Adam coordinates is an option or it's a
that's an option for correct
it's an option for molecule atom count
is a function and in list as a function
is this bad
well some things changed color but
others did not great so that I mean that
that would seem good would you like me
to go to the prototype build
no I said I think it should work should
I run this again
but if if that is unable to connect to
the Pacolet server then you should
switch them okay um actually that worked
okay so first thing I really like the
idea of changing this to be chemical
bond for all of our chemical bonds um in
which case that should become chemical
bond q right yeah a chemical bond count
chemical bond list
make sense
yes so is there any notion of an
automatic bond where it knows whether
it's single double so let's say so if
you if you put it in a molecule the idea
is that it would automatically we would
default a single and then if if you had
it in a pattern if you omitted the
second argument we would take it to mean
any kind of bond I see Bob and I we are
interested in introducing an automatic
bond order assignment so that files
produced by chemical by electronic
structure software where they don't even
care about the bonds that's that's a
problem we need to solve right okay so
wait a minute so there's this two
different cases of the any bond or the
default bond rate that does seem a bit
confusing I don't but it seems like it
would be useful for people when they're
typing in a molecule to not have to
enter the the second argument of the
string for it to default a single well
okay but then maybe it canonical eise's
two single yes
okay I mean I guess that's okay that the
default meaning on entry is could be
automatic for a pattern and single for a
molecule
I mean is that other cases in which it's
totally obvious from the structure of
the molecule that has to be a double
bond yeah
now without assumptions usually well if
you get coordinates it can be quite so
if assumptions that there are no
implicit hydrogen's like that yeah
if all the atoms were present and there
were two carbons that only had two other
ligands besides the each other then it
would be a double bond okay but it's not
completely obvious so it's let's see
it's not gonna be trivial to implement
that okay yeah that name is horrifying
okay so you have a proposal Wow okay
molecule substructure indices well
certainly having something more specific
as a good idea a nested list of indices
of the atoms that match Pat okay so this
is in the adenosine molecule where are
the nitrogen's whether assume that if I
put in there the fully decorated you
know entity nitrogen it would work it
should I do not know that I have if you
entered in a molecule it definitely does
okay fine I'm just saying let's make
sure it does but oh yeah yeah okay cuz
that's the thing with these the molecule
patterns as I I have to hook everything
up manually because I'm creating an
internal structure
so I language okay
okay so
this is returning
why don't you call this molecule
substrate
positions or other indices what are
those things
okay how do how do I get back out okay
so this is
ie ie ie ie ie ie what the heck is this
so no no I mean this is look I mean we
could have a fully decorated molecule
substructure extract
right for now that does this if what
you're doing is you're filling in one of
these lists right so you're filling in a
list like this it's an extract function
yes yes so that is not a list of three
parts
no I know I'm totally confused this is a
list
I see that's not a pot specification
that's an index list yes so there are
two parts of the adenosine that that
match that are five membered rings yeah
that's the spec for for each of those
okay
um
so intimate so the question is we want
to function
you
okay hold on hold on so what is this now
- which is different from this one right
so would be a more versatile function
that could that returns that couldn't
wouldn't just return the item indices
you could also tell it you want it to
return the list of bonds that match the
pattern or the list of adam' objects
that I see but that would be a third
argument that would specify that exactly
well I like that idea actually
I mean we could we can implement that
and just not support a third argument
yet
if we're not ready for that it shouldn't
be too difficult
okay so then then it would be Adam
indices Adams would just be nitrogen
nitrogen carbon whatever right
so it that could also be entities if you
wanted to return entities for the atoms
yeah atom entities well what were you
saying you're saying the atoms could be
entities that are returned by default
right or I was saying it would be a
third another string there to return
element entities yeah okay but a
different string other than add some
indices right yes I think this is a good
design molecule substructure Chasen how
about getting both atom indices and bond
indices or would this second the third
argument be a list of types I think it
should be allowed to be a list of types
okay yeah I don't think that would
conflict with anything would they come
back as just plain lists or as an
association with keys so you know what's
what
um I think with an association with keys
would make things very clear for the
user what what they're getting I kind of
agree it's a little bit weird but I kind
of agree okay so wait a minute
molecule substructure we got weird
background noise by the way molecule
is it the case that what this should
actually be called I mean normally it
would be Michael substructure
couldn't we just call it molecule
substructure and it says it finds the
substructure that is compatible with
pattern but to me that feels like it
should return something that is that is
either a mod so to me it seems like it
should return a module fragment which I
haven't yeah right but it shouldn't it
return basically this
right so that's what molecule
substructure would return on its own
right so then that will be the default
case and if you wanted to get the atom
indices you would say comma atom indices
that would get you the naked atom
indices but the default would be just
return me if I want these these aromatic
rings or whatever they are five five
membered rings what I would say is
molecule substructure of AD Anno seen ,
molecule pattern this and then I would
get back all the five five membered
rings in a nano-sim which seems rather
nice
yeah yeah I like that okay so that gets
that's gets around us having to do all
of this stuff here because if we had a
way to specify a molecule substructure
of that pattern instead of being a
molecule pattern was a naked collection
of atom indices see what I'm saying then
we could get away with them then that
would give it killed two molecules with
one stone so to speak
did that make any sense yeah yeah no
this is definitely clear huh I'm each
new instead of a stone photochemistry
yes h-bar Omega in my world did you
don't really say do people really is H
in chemistry time what
no H lowercase H means H and H bar both
yeah physics it's almost always H bar
and chemistry it's almost always H huh
unless your theoretical physical chemist
and you go right yeah okay that's H bar
anyway okay no you can't have both H and
H bar equal to 1 then you have trouble
ok no case alright so basically the idea
would be this is the extractor and then
molecule substructure of that and then
this by default if you just give a bunch
of naked yeah you could extract the
particular bond you could extract so
this would extract
that single singleton object like this
molecule fragment like that this would
extract multiple molecule fragments yes
exactly okay all right good
nice molecule substructure I like very
much that seems like a very useful thing
all right what's next
um
so in the list of symbols up at the top
there's a the ones in blue are the ones
we have not touched on in detail what is
molecule value again it's the the
property accessor function
alright so things like entity value the
analog of entity value rate rate and
it's not a bomb we've talked about
connected molecule components most so I
have I have such sections for those down
at there all right okay
fine let's go ahead school contains Q is
that that's a tester for molecule
substructure exactly
okay
so we want to call it Molly Chris Upshaw
Chuck you know I like the contains cute
yeah I think contains us fine okay and
all it would say in this case is yes
it's got a five membered ring be happy
yes
okay so modify molecule is that still on
the table right we let's see we design
modify molecule so as to avoid having
ten or twelve new symbols I'm kind of
joking there a little bit but it has
there are a whole different host of ways
to modify a molecule and modify and so
that function okay alright so down here
modify molecule oh my gosh my gosh my
gosh
so let's look at the syntax one of these
things molecule modify add atom
come free-floating atoms somewhere is
that right freight and there's an option
to turn off adding extra hydrogen's I
include hydrogens are of true or false
well so in this case yeah I could hook
it up to include hydrogen's in this case
I'm calling it at the moment
let's see fix valence I would just do
include hydrogen's I think it's or we
might want to generalize the name
include hydrogen slightly if we don't
like that right okay um
question how is the discussion about the
interactive editor going so let's see so
the amount of JavaScript that I need in
order to really make it a polished
Wolfram language product is I I would
need to learn some more JavaScript in
order to do that problem but what about
the our our friends the internal PO can
take aren't they prepared to do that I
think to a certain extent so you should
push them on that because I think they
will be prepared to do it and they have
people who know that stuff you really
should encourage them to do it and see
whether he can't get something if not
for 1204 the 1200 timeframe not too long
thereafter they should you should point
out the timeframes okay please do
because I think that this is something
they can they can do and they want it so
you know it's a it's a win for everybody
okay all right so this just randomly
adds atoms is that correct so if I say
molecule M equals that molecule what the
heck happened there okay so apparently
uh let's see so you can erase that and
write a molecule the string caffeine
okay so I recently moved everything from
one context and we see that summary
boxes actually hide some stuff that we
don't well that has me confused maybe
maybe quit the kernel something went
wrong
okay who knows why that looks nice looks
better than did before actually I think
Stephen you deleted the quit that was up
there and loading it required a quit
would you remove eyes here okay okay so
modify molecule I wonder if that this is
the right form molecule modify molecule
whether it should be some kind of
molecule molecule modify I don't know
seems kind of silly add at him okay so
let's say I had a tungsten to this thing
okay so I've got a ran a little tungsten
hanging out there so okay so let's take
a look at what some of these others are
so then so now you could add a bond from
that tungsten to say carbon how would I
do that
so then modify molecule percent you know
and oh man add bond mm-hmm then what and
then we can use the tooltips to figure
out what the proper indices are 25 okay
so what do I do so I say chemical bond
so I have done single bond 25 and then I
would pick one of those is it like this
no so it's it's just chemical bond will
have a list as the first argument good
cuz that's better I wanted that for a
while 25 comma what would I do 3 or
something I can I put it on so two
looked good so you want to pick
something that has an extra hydrogen
that it could just lose okay so now I
could say something like a molecule plot
aren't you
just to me more jolly um why I know we
have no we can't atom type for for
tungsten what do you mean
so the the embedding code wants to have
an atom tied for it to categorize every
atom that's in there and tungsten isn't
one of the supported atoms generally cuz
we because we don't know the physics of
it or what rate
so which atoms do we know that error
message is unhelpful right okay so say
why it's failing I mean because we don't
support tungsten it's cannot compute
molecular structure for tungsten if
that's why it's failing so that's why
it's failing is it yes so we you can get
a pretty decent structure if you just
take the graph of that make a graph 3d
of it using spring embedding and then
use the molecule machinery to kind of
make that a better structure but it's
it's not reliable enough for it to be
released yet okay well fine but so for
now just say contains a molecule we
don't know how to deal with but make
sense yeah I'm making uh no no okay
all right so
okay so delete item three or something
would just do the right thing right and
it doesn't it will also delete any
dangling hydrogens the hell is that that
seems weird I mean I thought it there
would be a a redox reaction or some
weird thing like that transformation
this means a transformation now I'm
totally confused to means the geometric
transformation well I don't understand
even what that could possibly mean so it
applies you know you're trying to talk a
molecule for example into an active site
of an enzyme and you want to move it
from one place to another
so wait a second so you're saying that
this is taking the 3d geometry of the
molecule
and simply moving it in space is that
correct well in that case we did a
scaling transform okay okay fine but but
so there's an issue here you know you
don't have the 3d geometry of the
molecule how in other words I might want
all you're giving me is the molecule
plot for graphics by the way got a bunch
of background noise could we cut it out
please the UM
you see what I'm saying we don't have a
function which gives the geometry of the
molecule do we I mean we can say graph
of a molecule if I say for this uh for
example if I say graph of that then I
will get the graph won't I know I
thought we were gonna get the graph from
this so let's see so percent seven is it
is graphics right no no okay so you're
saying if I get the molecule here right
then can I say graph of that you need to
use molecule graph
what is molecule graph I thought we
agreed we would have a graph function
that just how do we still have molecule
graph right it doesn't seem right to
give graph an option
fair enough okay so that was one of our
functions from up top here yes it was
good okay so is it the case that we
should have molecule geometry as well
so right now you can you can access the
geometry through a molecule valuer
through a sub value just atom
coordinates in a graph you use the
function graph why did that not work
so when you convert a graph that has an
edge rendering function into a graph 3d
is that a problem with the graph
functionality Roger maybe even speak to
that Roger Roger here yeah Charles you
know Charles is here what is this why so
it's half ship force on display the
shift function given by the user so but
it shouldn't give a pink box it should
either give a message or it should do
something right but a pink box is not a
good answer right and pink box with a
dollar failed thing isn't a good answer
I can I can meet with Charles to see how
I could design the molecule graphs so
that when you make a graph 3d of it yes
since you just told me that making a
graph 3d is the el cheapo way to add
random atoms right yeah I mean this
should work there's a bug in the graph
stuff that this is causing it to say
failed and anything that should not be
possible to get from this do you agree
Charles in principle no I mean we we
cannot verify to the result of the shape
force on that you be a valid object to
harness I see what you're saying I see
well okay so then then it's more for
this case it's more for the case of
Jason coming up with something more
reasonable for this okay I can find some
kind of shape function that works in
okay so what I want to know is does
molecule geometry make any sense what
what would you expect it to be
I'm not certain I'm not certain but I
mean this by the time you're doing the
scaling transform what is it what is it
transforming the only thing you're
transforming is atom coordinate I soon
yes or do you always just dealing with
points basically yeah
I think what this should say is I mean
this should apply transformation is
definitely not the right name it might
be something like transform coordinates
would be better
see what I'm saying yeah yeah I think
that's a name but it it does you know
I'm okay with this actually now that I
understand what it is there if we call
it like apply transform coordinates or
transform atom coordinates
you know then we really know what we're
doing make sense yes apply transform is
to your right as too vague and you first
thought it was doing a chemical reaction
type of transformation yeah
so specifically saying geometry or atom
coordinates is needed okay all right I
mean I'm not even sure why isn't it
applying an arbitrary function to that
is that what this is doing a scaling
transform on what I don't even know what
the scaling transform does to something
like just a coordinate vector yeah okay
so just as applying the function right
so there's an arbitrary function that
you get that right right okay so
keep going until each item okay next up
replace Adam
perhaps there should be replaced part
I'm sorry perhaps there should be
replaced part why well not if you say
delete item is working the same way
delete item works with indices as well
right yes
I mean somewhat confusingly add atom
just adds an atom floating in the soup
whereas replace is an index based thing
I think it's okay I think that's okay
add bond
chemical bond I'm not sure so let's just
look at what I bond does okay so that
just adds a random bond do you think ad
is the right word I mean this thing that
just put something into the soup so Jose
had once I don't think that's right
either but I mean that the factors that
add I guess it's okay because it can be
connected to the thing all right okay
fine
um okay canonicalize
so wait a minute - wait wait wait wait
wait wait are you saying there's a
curried form of modified molecule yes
okay if there's a curried form you
better not have three argument cases
here right this is not a good idea then
then what you want to do is add a time
an arrow whatever but otherwise you're
gonna have ambiguity in the curried form
oh I'm sorry what am I saying what am I
saying nonsense nonsense nonsense
nonsense nonsense so so it's always the
case that you have a action and a
payload right yes although sometimes the
payload is is no less when it's okay but
this is not um yeah Sandra Ostrom is
pointing out there's edge ad and vertex
ad so it makes sense to have a term ad
except that it's called a data rate and
I mean the reason that we have edge ad
and vertex I believe that previa
previous package had used ad edge that's
not the reason okay Charles can you
speak to that please Charles no no you
named those functions you named edge ad
etc right what I think we generally have
a bunch of operations that start with
edge you do start with vertex okay well
so maybe this should be a term ad I
don't know I'll add some seems more
natural in this case but you understand
you're gonna have ambiguity if you have
a two argument if you always have the
three argument case then the curried
form you see canonicalize how does this
degenerate into one no that can't be
right
come on come on look look modify
molecule of molecule comma canonicalize
so the I don't know so the reason it
seemed to work for me is that the non
curried form will always have a molecule
as the first argument yeah all right
although many of our other functions the
operator would come first
alright okay do you think canonicalize
is a clear enough name here it's
probably okay right I mean as a
standalone function you would want to
call it canonical molecule or something
like that right
okay
so if I say how do I make a blanket
molecule I just say molecule of nothing
look what do i do how do I make a blank
molecule so it would be two empty lists
this like this also a list an empty list
of atoms and an empty list of bonds okay
I don't think it does anything at the
moment sugar I think it should if you've
got given that you've got this whole a
data nonsense so should it format is a
summary box I think so just as an empty
molecule that the unmarked you'll I
would think because then what I wants to
do okay so let's say I say okay so what
you're saying is if I say molecule and
then all I have here is a solitary
oxygen like that all that like this and
oh my gosh it made itself into water
even before I knew it right so the goal
here is to in boy those protons really
get around sorry go on
no no the goal is to return a useful
molecule as as often as possible
yeah I understand so if I were to put
just for fun by the way somebody should
report Manu you're here you can report
the weight cut the the insertion cursor
is still wrong here
okay the horizontal insertion cursor is
now
now why didn't that make ozone
because you would need to have the bonds
in no I say okay fine
okay
renumber Adams what the heck does that
do
so not useful in most situations but
occasionally you have two copies of the
same molecule that you got from
different sources but there they have
their atoms in different orders okay but
so you probably also want to support the
case where that's a list of replacements
that makes sense
you
I want you to try and guess what this
actually does well perhaps I should what
is that doing I mean what does it do
isn't it it was an L or a D what is it
what does it do so in this case it's it
would be it would represent the the the
racemic mixture or just an unspecified
stereochemistry
how could we represent the mixture so as
soon as it was out of my mouth I might I
knew it was wrong I know it's it just
represents unspecified the racemic
mixture would be a bulk quantity which
we're not attempting to handle here you
could have you know a deform and an elf
form or an RNs form present you know the
two of them together as a pair but it's
still not what one would call a racemic
mixture yeah okay
you
what is this so this is what is this
generates coordinates and returns a
molecule with coordinates specified
what is this doing
can you explain it right so so you take
a molecule where the the atom
coordinates are automatic it returns a
molecule with with the automatic
coordinates filled in okay I don't think
that's why don't you call it set atom
atom coordinates or something well what
is it wait where you give it the atom
coordinates right so you could you could
also let's see so this is what this is
the the function that a user will use to
generate new coordinates what do you
mean by to generate so this is so it
calls the embedding algorithms and
generates them from whole cloth so embed
molecule is most definitely not the
right name um
with graph we have different methods to
do a graph layout which includes
essentially the the embedding of the
vertices in I mean I would have
explained this would be an option to
molecule that possibly we could redo by
saying by rewrapping molecule and so on
so the fact is it's going to have a lot
of a lot of options method options but
oh right but so why isn't this just
something in molecule itself where it's
deciding how to do this I mean in other
words it's got molecule but what is
photographs what's the embedding option
mechanism isn't there an embedding
option roughly out arrow whatever right
yes okay so what I'm suggesting is that
there's a
I mean in the end well doesn't there's
the the Assam coordinates how do you
specify the atom coordinates in a
molecule using the atom coordinates okay
so why isn't it the case that this is
atom coordinates that redoing the atom
coordinates
it's just molecule with atom coordinates
arrow and then something which says you
know automatic or whatever that redoes
them
you get what I'm saying so let's see so
normally it says automatic and then you
would there would be something else that
says fill in or something right what
does pullin mean what would what do you
mean by filling um as in let's see
calculate them at the time that we are
entering the expression calculate them
ahead of time and store them in the
expression I understand so so calculate
now and return in that molecule instead
of automatic I mean we could have a
string there Adam coordinates arrow
stored or something I don't know what
you want there or that could be
something which is a whole elaborate
Association that specifies what to do to
compute the Adam coordinates
you're getting hard to hear can you get
closer to yeah so I feel like for a lot
of chemists that this is going to be one
of the the most important functions to
them and when why why what is it doing
which it's generating structures from
which you could then feed to your
electronic structure calculations but I
mean we're doing that automatically
right why isn't that happening
automatically
that's what molecule does it would
provide a particular set of coordinates
so what is the way to what this is also
automatically generating coordinates yes
or no yes so if you don't by any options
then it will just generate them
automatically okay so so you're saying
there are a bunch of options which God
knows whether this is an ambiguous
syntax or not um
you know - there's a bunch of options to
modify molecule which are really options
to set atom coordinates right
right
or what is it really compute Adam
coordinates evaluate Adam coordinates
because that's what it's doing here
right
yes right um so the the name embed
molecule it's not gonna happen yeah but
it that it that would have some cachet
with with chemists I don't care okay
extremely obscure it's really mostly
only used for distance geometry for the
embedding and that's the default method
in the library there are other ways of
generating sets of coordinates for
molecules as well that are not the same
and they are not necessarily an
embedding process here you know what if
there's a specific way of setting
coordinates that you want to put in here
we should do that but embed molecule
doesn't cut it because to me embed
molecule means stick the molecule in
something else right I agree with you
I'm just so so this is a specific method
if this wants to be you know recompute
the atom coordinates with some specific
method let's name it that way if you
want this to be a general way of
computing atom coordinates that can
support many methods presumably those
many methods could also be supported
directly in the molecule object itself
then let's do that
but let's decide what it is
so if it's the molecule object itself
the molecule the head molecule could
take a molecule as an argument like
graph can and then we would have an
option that says to do something to the
molecule for example an option that
would redefine what the coordinates were
just one set right just just one second
I'm sorry sorry go ahead
yep right so so I've like compute atom
coordinates either as a function on its
own or as a modified molecule it should
be modified molecule okay
and so then there are some named named
methods that in the documentation page
we would point to the publication where
those come from who cares how are you
gonna specify them you would then be
saying um but in the molecule itself
before you modify anything you've got to
have a way of computing the atom
coordinates right in the molecule
so so if in the molecule it's Adam
coordinates goes to automatic and you
feed this to compute Adam coordinates no
I understand but if you if if in the
molecule itself you want to specify
which method you are using there has to
be a way to do that right so you could
do Adam coordinates goes to and then a
string or a list of rules that are the
options for well you'd have to give some
Association I think for that I mean so
in this case then what you're suggesting
that you do is modify molecule of
molecule comma and then you say compute
Adam coordinates
yeah that's okay that's okay that's okay
so then then the the and the third thing
would be either automatic or the string
the method is right right or is it reset
Adam coordinates
which is it I like compute because it
specifically points out that we are that
it's a non-trivial task okay fine
all right okay terrific energy what the
heck what is this
so this uses the force field to to find
the local okay so this is in fact
compute item coordinates again but with
a different method
right right so set computer Adam
coordinates doesn't by default minimize
the the energy because a user might want
to have a diversity of confirmations but
so we could make minimize an option to
compute Adam coordinates and combine
well I say computer Adam coordinates and
then the method is energy minimization
but I don't understand energy
minimization like for a protein or
something is super difficult right so
people don't actually do it so for a
protein it might take a considerable
amount of time but for a smaller
molecule like the kind there it's not
okay so then this could be a method for
computer atom coordinates but is it a
thing you do very often so I think it
would be something that users might do
and some users might okay well fine so
it needs a name but it's got to be a
name that is about um
it can't be energy minimized because
that I mean
what would it be I mean what would be
the right thing to say would be
something like so force field minimize
something to point out that it's that
it's using a force field it is giving it
a new set of coordinates like the others
so it should follow that same type of
space so I know it's time method would
be instead of creating him de novo by
some particular method some methods
would take existing coordinates and then
subject them to an energy minimization
for example or something else to change
they should be at the geometry okay so
how about energy minimize atom
coordinates
I would have thought it would have been
something more like you know modify
coordinates whatever we're gonna call
that and then the particular method is
energy minimize or that's fine I mean
that than that that will work fine if
you're prepared to have that there then
this will become just purely this energy
minimize so I actually like to keep
these separate just because let's see so
with the force field minimizing
eventually we're gonna have nice syntax
for adding constraints so I want the
bond angle between atoms three six and
seven to be be 30 degrees or I want it
to be a hundred and twenty degrees and
all right look maybe we just say
modified molecule energy minimize energy
minimize configuration or something
this is kind of like the the spring
electrical embedding for a graph and
there are a number of sub options there
that can control that in terms of
settings spring force constants and so
on well how is it done for a growth I
don't remember the details I Charles
speak up please
well it's two sub options of a method op
of the graph layout and then it's sub
options of graph layout is that right
yes and I would expect this would be
something similar to supply the method
options which could include the
constraints so what do you think this
should be called
okay so we're saying compute Adam
coordinates using some random method and
then this is why not just energy
minimize Adam coordinates its proposed
but that's what I was suggesting yeah
it's fine fine with me and this would be
equivalent is that correct okay yeah
yeah yeah and the second would be a
shortcut help yep okay continuing sorry
I'm gonna run out of time that's why I'm
being more happy here
you
okay and this is going to look like
molecule pattern bla aro blah is that
correct yeah magnificent
okay
that was that so replace substructure if
it finds multiple instances of the
substructure on the whole place with the
same thing yeah but here it does them
one by one pretty weird
which is the more common case to want
this one is it's kind of a crapshoot
right because it's because you don't
actually know which order the the
molecule pattern is going to come out in
right in to be honest I'm not sure what
is gonna be the most common case I'm
really curious to get feedback sorry
was there an answer to what order they
come out in I don't think it really
matters replaced list returns a list of
the different replacements and the that
order may be deterministic but it's not
always obvious what it is
yeah I understand so here in the same
order that the substructure match yeah
so it should return them in the same
order as the the substructure hold that
molecule substructure didn't mean right
so molecule substructure with atom
indices that would that's the same order
that but now wait a minute
if there's a multiple match here it's
going to give a list of molecule the in
that case it's going to give a list of
fragments is that correct
if
matches in multiple places it gives a
list of fragments correct yeah yeah
although I mean now that I mean I'm
thinking about it I mean they should be
it would be a list of practically
identical things unless the patterns
were nonspecific yeah the plate could be
completely different I mean they could
be identical or they could be different
right I mean if you ask room for all of
these rings it's that it's the cases
case so to speak right so if there's a
single one that matches I mean listen
this isn't very exciting if you give a
literal for Pat here this is just going
to return itself
it's gonna return pat assuming pat is
found actually it's not just going to
return Pat it's going to return Pat as a
molecule rate so so that brings up an
interesting point that if it just finds
the pattern once it would be returning a
single molecule but if it finds it
multiple times in the list Nance of
molecules I mean isn't a problem a list
of molecules right yes I don't think
that's hugely problematic that that well
I'm not certain we might want to always
return a list I'm not sure
no Mary Berber I don't think we need to
I think it's better to always return a
list
so the normal way of dealing with that
would be to have the third argument
where you can specify a number of to
return yeah except you've just blown
that by having this though you could
have a fourth argument I suppose and you
could sort of have a
as a courtesy support the third argument
being that number yeah but that's still
it's even if it's a singleton it's gonna
be a single length list yes
that's what the other functions do yeah
I mean okay I think it wouldn't be bad
to have an end there because otherwise
you get in some situation where you're
finding 700 different you know if you
say find me well I don't know I don't
know maybe these molecules are big
enough to the matters are they I'm
worrying about some kind of
combinatorial explosion but maybe that
won't happen users will some will try
and make huge molecules and do this
that's not a bad idea yeah okay all
right but then then molecule
substructure is the thing that returns
the matched object so then if you wanted
to know what gets replaced I don't
really know why this isn't just saying
why you don't extract the molecule
substructure first and then simply give
a bunch of instead of molecule patterns
just molecule blah arrow blah you get
what I'm saying so in other words the
output from molecule substructure which
gives you a bunch of molecule objects
you should be able to say replace in the
molecule those molecule those raw
molecule objects not molecule patterns
the raw molecule objects with other
molecule objects--
so that so that brings up an interesting
point about training instantiated
molecules as patterns to we by default
remove the hydrogen's before searching
for them before treating them I don't
know I don't know anything about
chemistry I would think you do remove
the hydrogen's since these protons seem
to get around as we've been discussing
yeah and the other thing Stephen your
proposal about having a list of
molecules that you would be using to be
replaced the left-hand sides would still
map not to the specific instance that
they had come from but to the other
instances as well no that's not true if
it's a single molecule it's got it's got
actual if it's an actual molecule thing
that it's got actual atom indices in it
but our matching isn't using those
indices well then it's probably not the
right then no but then you've got two
cases that you need to cancel K you've
got the case of matching a molecule
pattern in which the indices are nothing
they're dead meat right right right it's
the same thing it's gonna happen with a
graph okay so in a graph if you've got
something with raw indices that say take
indices 11 14 and 17 and blow them away
and replace them by this that's one
thing to do the other is take this sub
graph independent of its indices and by
graph isomorphism figure out where it is
and replace it yes it's the same thing
in chemistry so I okay so what I'm
suggesting is that if you have a
molecule on the left hand side that has
raw Atem indices right in it and
presumably those atom indices don't have
to start at one and so on that they are
whatever you got from molecule
substructure correct saying replace so
for a molecule for any given molecule
the atom indices always start at one if
they don't then we need some way of
specifying that that's what I thought I
was going to that's what I thought I
just detected so when you do molecule
substructure
okay the question is does the thing
extract it's gonna need to know that
this was in other words I think the two
cases molecule pattern is the one that
Rican analyzes and does essentially sub
graph isomorphism but
yeah but molecule itself should not
reckon Annika lies and perhaps the
wrapper molecule pattern of molecule
should reckon Annika lies so hold on
though I a molecule that you that gets
returned by modify molecule or molecule
substructure has no idea of where it was
before its it's a fresh I understand
that wait a minute molecule substructure
I don't understand that doesn't make
sense to me molecule substructure it
seems to me ok so that molecule fragment
is is context-free so to speak is that
right yes hmm yeah that's not the case
for the with their graph right I mean
but since the beginning that's been the
distinction between the molecule and the
graph is in the molecule of the atoms we
canonicalize they real able themselves
well I mean it's they don't they didn't
have any labels to start with they were
just a list and they're only identified
by their well they're not just a list
they have position they have indices
yeah in the bond specifications okay but
so look so what we're saying just so you
know the the graphs even if you use
integers for your vertices those may not
in fact coincide with the indices
exactly do you understand you know they
don't know they are rican are there
always canonicalized they always you
know the indices are canonical ok so
what you put in E
if you happen to use integers we treat
them as as labels as the expression you
know there could be any expression yeah
right you're not special okay but let's
come back to this case okay because what
we're doing is if I say I want this
particular piece of sub structure to be
replaced by this okay it's kind of bad
that we don't have the pipeline that you
say I mean look in in an expression what
you will be doing is you would saying
position of blah that the problem is
that position and cases have been
conflated into one function here
right so in in the other case we would
say position of blah I mean so maybe
what it is is that we want molecule
substructures third argument to allow
something that gives you these
contextualized molecules somehow I see a
use for this this is you're right
Stephen we want specifically atoms four
eight and twelve or whatever well I
think we need a way to support what
Stephen wants to do it's just like
giving tags to them or something that
survives yeah I mean if those atoms had
names attached to them those names would
survive right Jason
idem so ideally I'm not entirely certain
that they should in general I think they
should as a molecular model or I would
expect names that have assigned to an
atom if I pull them out of a molecule as
part of a substructure I would expect
those names to survive unless I told
them to be replaced or regenerated de
novo okay so the zeroth order like for
first release they are not okay so
listen this is welcome to the world of
annotation calculus this new field that
we're in the process of inventing this
is an example of that issue that was
already invented in version 9 which
this question of whether you carry
things along how do you deal with it
with four graphs oh no I mean the
annotation calculus as in when do you
decide how you propagate the annotation
do you carry it along or not right yes
well done partially initial mine okay
well good um okay but but but back here
okay so what we've identified is that
there's an issue that we probably want a
special third argument for molecule
substructure that returns a thing that
is a contextualized molecular fragment
am I making sense and my guess is the
way that will work is that the molecule
itself will accept some additional thing
that gives a some kind of you know
mapping or something just like it has
atom coordinates okay which are an
arbitrary you know the coordinates yeah
here's a way to think about it okay you
have these atom coordinates but they're
very arbitrary in the sense that this
molecule could flip around in 3d space
and so on and have different coordinates
making sense so my claim is just like
you have an embedding of the molecule in
3d coordinate space so similarly you
have an embedding a molecule in in
molecular index space and that that's a
another kind of arbitrary thing that you
might want to give as an advisory
feature of the molecule did that make
any sense
I think I understand what you want there
Jason did that make sense to you right
so that you can so supply your own
indices exactly exactly just as you can
supply your own coordinates
Yeah right I think that's the right way
to think about it and then I mean we're
not going to get it for this version but
that's probably the right thing to do so
in other words when we say molecule
substructure we would say the default
for molecule substructure would just be
to return the substructure but we want
to have a case of that that says
wherever it was um I lost it here here
we go
molecule substructure so what I'm
suggesting here is
let's say something like molecule
relative that's not the right term but
um
our embedded
something like embedded that's not the
right term either okay something L
context there's the the the language
context structure that we already have
it's going to lead to confusion you know
I don't know I think the word
contextualized wouldn't be confusing but
how are you know that it's different
from the namespace context
contextualized there's a different way
this is not the right term
these are neither of these are the right
terms but something like this is what we
want and then the question is what what
the I mean actually that this might be
better as something like molecular
fragment
that might be the right term for it
right and so I hesitate to use molecule
fragment or molecule substructure at the
moment because I don't know I want I
like I envision there being that being
ahead for for this thing for a molecule
that is a fragment that has unfinished
bonds okay this is we're not gonna solve
this problem right now okay but this is
I think we've identified a relevant you
know a good direction to go and I don't
think whether the design we have right
now is going to cut anything off
okay set bond length okay set bond angle
that takes a triple yeah okay fine
okay chemical bond Q rating so this is
just utility to tell you are these two
bonded or not but wouldn't you want
wouldn't you want to compute the
chemical bond type
how would you find the chemical bond
type so you could use bond list on em
and then give let's see so you would do
bond list em and then the second
argument you would be you as of right
now it would be underscore 18 comma 3
and so would return anything in the list
of bonds that matches that what
underscore what are you saying bond does
come it's a chemical bond list of M
comma what so so I'm calm a blank comma
or 18 3 no no so blank is the head in
that case that's so right now weird no
that's just wrong that I know because
you've got single bond double bond
desert ok so what are you gonna do in
the real case here so would be a
chemical bond 18 comma 3 this like this
no with a hit chemical bond so that
doesn't make sense to me that doesn't
this doesn't make sense
this just doesn't make sense 3 and then
underscore yeah that doesn't make sense
there's no reason to do it that way
actually did that's almost like using
cases yeah why not just use cases well
so it's very much like edge list edge
list takes pattern in the second
argument I don't think that's the right
way to do it I mean I think okay so this
question about is it bonded right
why isn't that the same story as
chemical bond list that is if the bond
list is empty this is either gonna
return a bond or it's gonna return
nothing right right so bond bond queue
in this case just checks is that is that
list empty right but why do we need that
as a separate function is it really that
common I think it's fairly common to ask
or is there a bond between that right
Bob do you want to comment on that yeah
that would be something that would be
very useful to have all right okay okay
fine but but do you not want to know
what type of a bond it is sometimes you
want to know that as well depending what
you're trying to do but but it's useful
to have a function that is true or false
that you can have in a pattern test that
kind of thing what if we just asked for
the bond type and a returned single bond
double bond triple bond or missing you
know yeah he was available but but
missing not present or so I'm personally
using in my code condition right so okay
so so fine so this is a chemical bond
that would say is there a single bond
between those things that make sense
yeah and if you okay it'll give you any
bond okay okay so lost the this case of
chemical bond list okay this doesn't
make sense to me this is asking so so
for example a typical thing I might want
is a list so chemical bond list of em
just gives you all of the list all of
the bonds right correct yes is that
correct
okay so then if I want bonds with
tungsten atoms well okay so that's
single but if I want bonds between
tungsten atoms and something else how
would I get that so you would type a
chemical bond list and chemical bond and
then in place of one of the indices you
would put add of you
in the other for the other index you
would put an underscore so I suppose you
could omit the chemical bond now that we
don't have single bond double bond
triple bond yeah
well then so then what we'd end up with
is you know is something where we're
saying you know something like this
comma single might be the reasonable way
to do it
it's that right right yeah so Adam list
though is a two argument form rat rather
than a three argument because in an atom
list so you give it some type of atom
pattern as the second argument and you
can make that into a rule if you want to
access atom properties when are you
doing that with chemical bond as well so
I don't have bond properties set up
right now but I want to okay so that
would end up being something where it
where rather bizarrely it would look
like this yeah all right I am gonna have
to go very very soon so I just wanted to
have a quick quick look through these
other things so provisionally I think
this is gonna make sense but I think we
need to be careful about them maybe this
is an alternative form if every bond
oh boy I was going to say half triple
split the bond in them but that's silly
it's horrible okay I think this is a big
deal right
right now Julie equal is not a trivial
function but here I'm showing that if
you just create a cyclohexanol and then
you grab the cyclohexanol from our
knowledge base the two are obviously not
same q although they probably should be
I mean so the data in our knowledge base
the the atom order and everything that's
not something I can I mean yeah well we
should redo that when we should do it so
that we yeah I think we should do it so
that they come back the same but okay so
molecule equal fantastic I mean that
seems like a great thing to have and and
presumably it's the case that if I say
molecule modify oops I it's modify
molecule isn't it yes maybe we should
call it molecule modified
you
I think we should call it molecule
modifying okay yeah I mean yeah okay so
anyway I do molecule modify a
canonicalize to both of these then they
will be same q correct
they really should be
you
okay I'll kill contains key we talked
about
so since the molecule structure allows
disconnected components oh boy
you this business about keeping
coordinates my friend okay you are being
totally inconsistent right if you keep
coordinates so that your molecules fit
together like a nice set of puzzle
pieces but you don't keep indices Yuri
canonicalize the indices what is going
on to get what I'm saying yep so I don't
see the okay because okay you can
recenter the molecule on center of mass
okay and which means you're recognizing
the coordinates so to speak you take a
fragment from the molecule Yuri
canonicalize the coordinates but yet you
are choosing not to do that but you're
choosing to reckon annika lies in atom
index space you're not recognizing in
physical space but you are recognizing
an atom index space to get what I'm
saying so you obviously want in in
molecule modify you obviously want
something that essentially Reiss enters
the molecule did you get what I'm saying
okay yeah yeah but that shouldn't always
happen well I don't know you tell me I
mean no it shouldn't if you're changing
just a bond length you would expect part
of the molecule to stay fixed wherever
the coordinates were okay fine but then
but then what is happening then in these
functions molecule substructure okay so
what we've agreed is molecule sub
structure needs the two cases and maybe
they'll end up as an option in the end
the two cases of okay so there are
actually four cases right there's do you
recenter the coordinates and potentially
re re rotate the thing right to some
canonical rotation and do you and I want
to talk about chemical rotation in a
second and do you re re canonicalize the
atom indices I'm making sense yes there
there are all of those variations okay
so those are probably going to need to
be options in molecule sub structure
I think yep and we just have to find a
reasonable default behavior right which
I think you are arguing is redo the
autumn indices don't redo the
coordinates the physical coordinates hey
can I can I can I talk about the
orientation of molecules how do you
determine the canonical orientation for
a molecule so we find the primary
moments what happens the first
degenerate moments there aren't because
the the masses of isotopes are non
commensurate in some weird way so you
can I mean you can have a linear
molecule sure that then it doesn't
matter right but I'm saying there's no
degeneracy if the if the masses of
isotopes were integers there could be
degeneracies I claim
but the Chancellor it's like hashcode
the chance of a degeneracy is extremely
low but I don't think chemists usually
worry about that they would expect
benzene to be degenerate no no no I'm
saying I'm said I'm saying the following
point I'm saying that could be too if if
you are orienting the molecule using the
principal moments of inertia right right
then it could be the case that there are
there are a molecule what am I saying
that has a where you can't am i right
where you have perhaps more canonical
forms that it would come to yeah that's
right but I think that probably can't be
in this case okay so connected molecular
components seems okay
connected molecules - oh my gosh this is
sliding down the slippery slope of what
is a molecule and is sodium chloride a
molecule so it's a Wolfram language
molecule but it would not be connected
molecule q I mean so this is a case
where it'd be fine I would be more than
happy to have connected paths you
overloaded on a molecule yeah well in
connected components could be overloaded
here as well right but that returns the
list of indices don't we have a way of
finding we do have a way for graphs we
added that recently it's called graph
components or something and that returns
a list of graphs so there's also
connected components which returns to
the lists of this is a little bit kind
of worms this thing about connected
molecules is a bit of a can of worms I I
feel like those worms aren't when I'm
not gonna do them justice in these
couple of minutes here um right so this
was just a briefly show that I
implemented styles here
style where is that right so in the
bottom one you have a style six membered
ring is defined as a molecule pattern up
above and here you're just saying that
you want it to be this particular shape
wow that's pretty that's pretty
space-age that's nice I'm finally gonna
learn something about chemistry this is
exciting it's naturally easy enough to
use that you know okay I'm just we have
a question a comment from a live stream
from sander if you have a ch3 tail that
is connected to another carbon how do
you specify the rotation of that thing
oh gosh it's or the torsion angle yeah
right so yeah so afraid so I'm not
proposing it as a system symbol yet
until probably the next version but
right now you can access the molecule
value so you would tell you you want the
torsion angle right but so what he's
pointing out is if you attach that tail
somewhere it is degenerate
the thing can spin around right in
principle when you attach it or am I
wrong no you're right it's it's well
it's not degenerate it's unspecified
yeah it's unspecified and it might but
there's an energy minimization which
would cause it to be a particular thing
so that's true you could do that and
there are some heuristic rules that
could also be used to position it and if
you connected it to your molecule I
would expect that you would use the
heuristic rules for the correct distance
an angle to some other atom and torsion
angle to yet a third atom two bonds away
that's what we would normally do so
combine molecules or change structures
or whatnot
may generate new coordinates as if it
were a whole new molecule right okay I
know it shouldn't it shouldn't supply a
whole new set of coordinates well I mean
what you're talking about will take some
time to implement and it's not done yet
so okay now as we've talked about right
okay spectacular stuff a few loose ends
but we're getting really close here and
I think the next time around we probably
should see guide pages and so on and I
assume you guys gonna drop those right
rates we've been working on that okay
it's very exciting functionality really
exciting functionality in my opinion
it's great it's really you know it
brings in to the sort of easy
computational domain a whole new range
of things and and yeah anyway wonderful
all right okay thanks everybody
um see you soon thank you okay